[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre en ce 2 novembre
pour une nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information locale au cours de
la prochaine demi heure nous reviendrons
sur la fermeture du plus grand centre de
vaccination de france le plus grand
vaccinodromes le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ne peut
dorénavant accueillir 300 personnes par
jour contre l 5000 depuis mars dernier
saint quentin en yvelines réduit donc la
voilure nous évoquerons aussi elle la
trêve hivernale qui s'applique depuis
hier et jusqu'au 31 mars les expulsions
locatives les coupures de gaz et
d'électricité elles sont interdites en
plateau l'administrateur dans les
yvelines de l'association solidarités
nouvelles pour le logement et à la fin
de ce journal les résultats sportifs du
week-end de ce long week end elle des
images du gala de boxe des mureaux mais
aussi de la course pédestre de poissy et
un point sur la coupe de france de
football
[Musique]
l'actualité de ce début de semaine c'est
également l'annoncent par le groupe ces
lentilles ce qui produit les véhicules
peugeot citroën fiat ou encore opel et
chrysler de la création d'un campus de
60 mille mètres carrés dans les yvelines
en 2024 sur les bords de seine à poissy
plus de onze mille salariés seront
regroupés au sein d'un nouveau site de
production ils quitteront trappe vélizy
carrières sous poissy objectif principal
pour le groupe limiter l'empreinte
carbone le maire de la commune de poissy
karl olive salut je cite une formidable
nouvelle pour l'attractivité économique
du territoire
sur le front de la lutte contre la copie
de 19 à présent les centres de
vaccination ferment progressivement
leurs portes pendant que les pharmacies
notamment prennent le relais à saint
quentin en yvelines le plus grand centre
de france réduit donc à son tour la
voilure après plus de 350000 injections
réalisées depuis mars dernier
dès cette semaine c'est un mini centre
qui accueille le public elle les
précisions de michael et mido
la vaccination s'adapte au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
fini le méga centres situés sur l'air
central de la structure un mini centre a
ouvert ce 1er novembre sur le site
conséquence du ralentissement de la
vaccination en france ces dernières
semaines vous savez je crois que c'est
un facteur 10
sait on retrouve toujours ce facteur
donc il ya dix fois moins
de vaccination aujourd'hui c'est
l'adaptabilité c'est la réversibilité
c'est l'agilité c'était une structure
comme qui s'est adapté je vous dis à un
petit besoin comme au début et
aujourd'hui est un gros besoin la
structure est passé d'une vingtaine de
médecins sur l'air centrale à trois
boxes avec deux médecins et une
infirmière richard baudet présents sur
le site depuis mars dernier comprend
cette décision sont ça normal c'est bien
qu'on soit redescendue parce qu'on avait
beaucoup moins de travail donc on est
passé de plusieurs milliers à quelques
centaines donc
cette évolution me trouve je trouve ça
plutôt favorable et sympathique
aujourd'hui avec ce nouveau format le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peut vacciner
jusqu'à 300 personnes par jour
oui peut-être vous êtes juste venu ce
matin que ça roule bien qu'il ya
régulièrement des patients qui viennent
on n'a pas de périodes d'attentes
importante et on n'a pas non plus
d'affluence énorme grâce au rendez-vous
qui ont été pris et que les gens
respectent et bien tout se passe bien ce
nouveau mini centre est ouvert du lundi
au vendredi de 9h à 15h depuis mars 2021
le vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines avec ciné plus de 350 mille
personnes
l'actualité du jour c'est l'ouverture de
la trêve hivernale jusqu'au 31 mars il
est impossible d'être expulsé de son
logement même si la loi prévoit des
exceptions des droits et des devoirs
donc pour les propriétaires les
bailleurs et les locataires les détails
avec mélanie poker pas d'expulsion
possède un locataire jusqu'au 31 mars
2022 c'est la notion que l'on connaît le
plus de la trêve hivernale né en 1956
mais il ya des exceptions comme ceux
bénéficiant d'un relogement les
squatteurs ou en corse ayant commis des
violences mais qui dit trêve hivernale
ne dit pas fin des obligations pour les
locataires si les personnes concernées
par cette trêve ne sont plus redevable
du loyer elle le son d'une indemnité
d'occupation fixé par le jul qui
équivaut au montant du loyer et des
charges en cas de difficultés à payer
son loyer il existe des solutions on
vaut mieux continuer à payer autant que
faire se peut un on n'entend qu'eux il
ya six des locataires de bonne foi qui
ne peuvent pas payer tout simplement
mais là il faut qu'ils fassent des
démarchages les stands social peut-être
un dossier de surendettement mais
toujours payé le plus possible pour
aussi que la caf ait envie de continuer
à verser les apl et éviter que la dette
à la sortie sous la catastrophique la
trêve hivernale concerne aussi les
propriétaires bailleurs en cas de non
respect de cette trêve d'une peine de
prison allant jusqu'à trois ans et 30000
euros damende sont possibles
interdiction aussi de procéder à des
coupures d'électricité de gaz et de
l'eau les propriétaires bailleurs ou
posséder droit 6e il y as dont
ils ont besoin de ce loyer pour payer
les mensualités de crédit puisqu'ils ont
achetés notamment pour l'investissement
locatif ils pourront obtenir un délai de
grâce auprès du juge qui peut suspendre
du coup les mensualités durant deux ans
il peut aussi négocier avec la banque
qui peut elle aussi suspendre par contre
la banque très rarement vassues spa ne
suspendra pas les intérêts donc
l'intérêt continu un groupe courir mais
ces deux options ils peuvent eux mêmes
ce n'est tension est nettement la trêve
hivernale prendra fin le 31 mars 2022 si
les expulsions concernent très
régulièrement d1p l'adil note une
augmentation des motifs liés aux
troubles du voisinage
et pour évoquer cette question de la
trêve hivernale je reçois ibères macquet
bonsoir bienvenue en plateau vous êtes
administrateur snl yvelines snl pour
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
avant à d'évoquer votre association ses
missions également cette trêve hivernale
est ce qu'elle apporte un vrai
soulagement aussi pour les personnes les
plus en difficulté ou est-ce que
malheureusement ce n'est qu'un sursis et
vous craignez déjà la fin du mois de
mars
c'est très variable ça dépend beaucoup
des propriétaires et moi je vais vous
parler de notre association qui est
propriétaire d'un certain nombre de
logements et donc vous expliquer comment
ça se passe comment elle fonctionne vous
allez vous allez nous l'expliquer mais
avec le climat actuel à la hausse des
factures les os des factures d'énergie
gaz électricité et même de l'essence est
ce que d'ores et déjà il ya des craintes
sur des expulsions qui pourraient
reprendre dès les foyers qui vont
s'endetter pendant les mois à venir
encore il ya malheureusement toujours un
courant d'expulsion qui est plus ou
moins importants
qu'on a très peu disons qu'un
propriétaire un patient et de récupérer
son logement eh ben il va patienter
parfois difficilement il va peut-être
faire des pressions pour essayer de
faire partir le locataire 4 millions de
personnes seraient mal logés en france
avec votre association l'une de vos
missions c'est de témoigner de cette
situation pour que chacun puisse avoir
donc droit à un logement décent vous
agissez aussi j'aimerais qu'on parle des
actions que vous menez vous avez créé
les logements sociaux avec snl
l'association depuis 1997 comment cela
fonctionne déjà qu'on comprenne alors
outre le témoignage qui est quelque
chose de très important parce qu'il faut
bien savoir que le logement c'est la
base de tout
toute personne doit disposer d'un
logement en bon état pas en sucre en sur
occupation 1 parce que à partir au
moment où vous avez un logement vous
pouvez chercher du travail vous pouvez
héberger votre famille vous n'êtes plus
à la rue vous pouvez vous occuper de
votre santé
alors pour nous c'est capital c'est un
droit et d'ailleurs vous savez qu'il ya
une procédure qui s'appelle le droit au
logement opposable depuis plusieurs
années alors que faisons-nous plus
concrètement et bien premières tâches du
créons des logements sociaux
comme vous l'avez dit depuis 1997 on a
commencé modestement avec dix logements
est aujourd'hui dont vous voyez 25 ans à
peu près au delà eh bien nous en avons
125 mis en service on va voir les cartes
justement qui va s'afficher pour montrer
un peu la répartition de ces différents
logements 125 aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines la carte qui s'affiche et vous
voyez sont concentrés principalement sur
saint quentin en yvelines mais comme
comment vous faites l'acquisition de ces
logements comment ça fonctionne alors ce
que je voudrais quand même souligner
c'est que cette action elle est engagée
et menée tout du long par de simples
particuliers
bon nous avons évidemment vu la taille
nous avons démarré avec un salarié au
bout d'un an et aujourd'hui enfin au
début de l'année prochaine nous en
aurons 13 certains à temps partiel mais
l'idée c'est que toute personne enfin
beaucoup de personnes peuvent faire
quelque chose de concret pour
remédier à cette crise du logement alors
nous avons donc
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que nos
logements sont plutôt en centre-ville
et diffus c'est à dire on n'a pas grand
bâtiment oui les logements à l'intérieur
la bulle c'est dedans et pourquoi parce
que ça fout favorise l'insertion des
personnes qui sont défavorisés dans la
ville ils sentent c'est capital pour
leur bien-être
nous dans un deuxième temps nous gérons
c'est locataires qui sont arrivés chez
nous il ya aussi cette mission
d'accompagnement ce sera oui l'une des
questions que je vais vous poser au 6
mai mais je reviens quand même de suture
sur l'acquisition qu'on comprenne bien
oui les spectacles vraiment vous en
faites l'addition parce qu'il faut des
ressources méritait des logements sis à
loisir il ya trois sources si vous
voulez ce sont les locataires qui payent
des loyers la plupart de nos locataires
payent des loyers sur des loyers fixés
par les pouvoirs publics et notre
catégorie de logement c'est la catégorie
la plus basse ça fait à peu près un
tiers des recettes le deuxième 6
routière ce sont des subventions
publiques
pour le fonctionnement pour la
construction c'est assez compliqué selon
les différentes strates administratives
et le troisième tiers bas c'est tout
simplement nos membres nos membres
bienfaiteurs il y en a qui nous donne 20
euros par an il y en a qui nous donne de
temps en temps des chèques extrêmement
important il ya même dernièrement une
personne qui nous a donné un appartement
au moment où elle partait en retraite
donc vous voyez il ya toute une panoplie
on respecte toutes les normes toutes les
procédures de construction c'est assez
long mais on y arrive tout doucement on
a encore à peu près une petite dizaine
de logements en projet pour la fin de
cette année l'année prochaine et peut
être même au delà et donc avec cette
mission d'accompagnement on y vient vous
aider les gens qui viennent n'est pas
simplement entre guillemets là pour leur
trouver un toit et et voilà pour fo
aussi le parce qu'il ya une démission
qui est importante c'est que j'ai aussi
souligné vouloir apprenez que la
première dépense à régler c'est aussi le
loyer et ben voilà avant
l'accompagnement je voudrais parler de
la gestion parce qu'on appelle gestion
locative adaptée
pourquoi je dis adapté parce que nos
gestionnaires on a trois personnes qui
s'occupent de ça c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces locataires ce sont
des personnes qui ont en quelque sorte
subi des accidents dans leur parcours
dans leur vie et la préfecture veille
beaucoup à ce que nous prenions ce genre
de catégorie personnes ils ont souffert
d'handicap sociaux différents et nos
gestionnaires vont suivre avec une
grande attention tout ce qui concerne le
paiement des loyers il ya toute une
procédure de prévention de prévenir on
se réunit avec les personnes on essaye
d'analyser les causes de difficultés de
paiement mais au bout d'un certain temps
si nos rappels
ne sont pas efficaces on peut pas
accepter qu'une personne reste pendant
des mois sans payer
et pour être relogés parce que nous ce
sont des logements passerelle qui dure
trois ans raison médecins en non un an
mais renouvelable chaque année pour une
durée qui peut être variable et bien
nous pouvons menacé de ne pas renouveler
et la personne devra chercher mais en
fait si donc la personne ne tient pas
compte de nos avis et on est à la fois
très ferme et très conciliant ferme sont
les principes conciliant dans la
pratique
eh ben on finira par demander une
expulsion juge un ordre de grandeur
peut-être une expulsion tous les deux
ans à peu près c'est assez variable il a
peut arriver des abeilles en d2 ce
résultat qui est finalement plutôt
plutôt bon qui permet de à chacun d'eux
doit on faire c'est pascal travail
d'accompagnement est alors non pas
quelques mois on va être pris par le
temps donc comment se passe
l'accompagnement qu'il se fait de façon
nous avons des travailleuses sociales
qui sont des professionnels et qui vont
donc premier première tâche s'occuper
que les nos locataires et toutes les
allocations auxquelles ils ont droit à
une série d' d'allocations très
nombreuses et beaucoup d' allocation ne
sont pas demandées parce que les gens
n'y comprennent pas grand chose donc nos
travailleuses sociales sont là pour les
aider et puis nous avons aussi des
bénévoles qui habite dans le quartier à
proximité et qui rendent de petits
services ils peuvent ils participent à
l'emménagement de la personne il cherche
du mobilier ils peuvent garder un enfant
quand la mère doit aller chez le médecin
il bon dans le cas terre parfois ils ont
juste une valise ils n'ont pas de caisse
à outils et ben nous nos bénévoles
donnent un coup de main pour ne serait
ce que changer une lampe ou remettent en
place une prise c'est vraiment des
petites choses en fait on peut dire ce
sont de bons voisins et tous ces
bénévoles qui interviennent plus ils
sont nombreux mieux c est forcément
s'ils veulent vous rejoindre aussi
j'aimerais qu'on revoit une dernière
fois les coordonnées de l'association
qui qui s'affiche aussi bien postale que
par par mail ou par téléphone voilà ses
coordonnées vous pouvez les noter et
contacter si vous souhaitez verser des
dons et des justement vous l'avez
entendu même 20 euros par an pour ceux
qui le peuvent et et essai c'est à
saluer aussi d'offrir quelques fois
beaucoup plus comme des avortements vous
l'avez dit et puis intervenir au
quotidien comme de bons voisins voilà le
terme vous avez employé merci beaucoup
et bien ma tête je voulais 7 10 secondes
malheureusement pourquoi entrer je vais
vous dire mes raisons personnelles c'est
un travail utile ce que nous faisons et
deuxièmement ça beaucoup de chance
c'est très gratifiant pour les bénévoles
notamment
les donateurs ils sont un peu plus loin
évidemment
mais moi je vous le dis depuis que j'y
suis ça fait pas mal de temps après ce
que depuis la création je suis très
heureux merci beaucoup ce sera le mot de
la fin je rappelle l'action que vous
menez avec solidarités nouvelles pour le
logement merci encore à vous nous
poursuivons ce journal à présent avec
cette information le concours lépine a
été remporté par un yvelinois une table
basse qui peut se transformer en poste
informatique et bien c'est l'invention
qui a donc été primé ce week end au
concours lépine son nom jobs et apple
elle est l'oeuvre d'un habitant de saint
germain en laye omar seck un objet qui
s'inscrit clairement dans l'air du temps
avec la pérennisation du télétravail
dans de nombreuses entreprises on passe
aux sports à présent le club de boxe
anglaise des mureaux vient d'organiser
ce samedi un gala une soirée avec
plusieurs ceintures wba en jeu à
l'occasion de revoir du public dans les
gradins de montrer aussi que la ville
est un territoire un terreau fertile de
la boxe retour sur l'événement avec un
nicolas landry et bixente mais rien
senti très mal
il boxait à domicile a remporté son
combat le super-plume muriautin khalil
el hadri s'est imposé aux points face au
mexicain cristian lopez flores sa
troisième victoire consécutive depuis le
mois de mars 2021
[Applaudissements]
dominer les ventes parce que sans vous
vous êtes un troisième souffle
[Musique]
au programme de ce gala de boxe cinq
combats avec plusieurs ceintures wba en
jeu pour le plus grand plaisir du public
pour les gens qui ne sont pas trop du
monde de la boxe est plutôt un bon moyen
de venir regarder apprécié et surtout de
passer un bon moment en famille quoi je
sais que c'est des gros combats qui sont
attendus ce soir une belle soirée le
club de boxe des murs obame l'héritage
organise régulièrement des soirées de
gala
la dernière en date le 19 décembre 2020
l'occasion de confirmer que la ville est
un territoire de boxe on n'était pas
longtemps dans une salle qui était plein
et c'est bien aussi bien sûr
jean vianney cette bonne chose depuis
tout le temps je pense que les mureaux
c'est une vraie tête de boxe mais y'a
pas que les mureaux il ya le département
des yvelines
les mureaux en fait partie c'est la
locomotive et on veut continuer dans
cette voie mais ce qu'il faut c'est de
continuer dans la voie de la difficulté
est aujourd'hui c'est l'organisation
continue à trouver des partenaires qui
nous accompagnent qui nous font
confiance pour pouvoir faire de belles
soirées comme comme celle ci est un
nouveau rendez vous est déjà pris pour
accueillir encore plus de monde un
nouveau gala de boxe devrait être
organisé en avril 2022
en football les clubs des yvelines se
sont illustrés ce week end lors du 6e
tour de la coupe de france poissy s'est
imposé à 2 à 0 sur la pelouse du fc
fleury pendant que versailles également
à l'extérieur l'emporter 1 à 0 face à
neuilly-sur-marne tirage au sort des
prochaines rencontres du prochain tour
prévu ce mercredi à 11h30 c'est un
halloween sportif qui s'est déroulée ce
week end à poissy et la ville organisée
pour l'occasion une course à pied 270
personnes se sont hâtés lancé sur
plusieurs distances le reportage
la dont il réalise une première à poissy
ce dimanche 31 octobre à l'occasion
d'halloween la ville organise une course
inter générationnelle décalé au
programme trois tracés de 1 7 5 et 10 km
proposés en centre ville
un parcours en coeur de ville parce
qu'il ya certains commerçants qui sont
encore ouverts et si jamais on a besoin
d'aller chercher une petite brioche pour
pour se ravitailler ou aller boire un
coup on va pas gêner voilà c'est ça
l'esprit de poissy une course atypique
pour se dépenser dans la bonne humeur
aujourd'hui pas de chronomètre
l'important être nombreux sur la ligne
de départ 270 personnes ont participé
tout déguisés pour l'occasion le zombie
va prendre son temps et prendre du
plaisir avec ses enfants je suis
infirmière aujourd'hui une infirmière
commandes ya haute en couleurs est prête
à en découdre voilà c'est le zombie
police moi je suis je sais pas et lui
c'est le squelette
bonjour un peu les candy man je suis pas
si vous voyez le film un peu d'horreur
voilà vous prononcez que trois fois
qu'andy man et on apparaît moi je fais
pas la manière qui weber voyez ça se
voit c'est super sympa ça pour plein
d'activités comme ça tout autour de la
ville et donc du coup halloween c'était
la bonne occasion
l'événement a mobilisé 80 bénévoles et
agents de la collectivité la nomine res
2022 est d'ores et déjà pris
et qui dit halloween dit également
toussaint comme chaque année le 1er
novembre les fleuristes était prêt à
accueillir les clients pour réaliser
leur deuxième meilleur chiffre
d'affaires après les fêtes de fin
d'année rencontre avec mélanie qui tient
une boutique à montigny le bretonneux
après une période de la toussaint en
plein confinement l'année dernière les
fleuristes se réjouissent d'enfin
pouvoir retrouver leur clientèle dans
des conditions plus propices anémone une
boutique logé au coeur de montigny le
bretonneux à tout juste un an
heureusement l'année dernière ça a été
une grosse période ils ont beaucoup joué
le jeu pour nous soutenir due à la
période du coc vidé en plus de notre
notre ouverture toute
naissante comme chaque année les
fleuristes doivent mettre les bouchées
doubles pour tous à cette fête
traditionnelle marque un pic dans leurs
activités on a vraiment composé nous
mêmes tous ensemble des compositions
alors vous avez de l'ami donc ça c'est
pour le côté champêtre que moi
j'apprécie du giro fleix du livre du
chrysanthème bien évidemment un pour ce
week end pour le 1er novembre
composition et ornements floraux
viennent fleurir les tombes certaines
variétés ou plus particulièrement la
cote on retrouve beaucoup de
chrysanthèmes qui est la fleur par
excellence de la bruyère beaucoup de
brouillard de différents types de laits
les bords commencent aussi belle aussi
la rose de noël communément voilà de la
pensée avec un gagnant le chrysanthème t
la plante qu'on retrouve à cet âge là
c'est fleury il en existe de plein de
types et de formes différentes et ça
tient bien et puis c'est pas c'est parce
qu'ils aussi de le plus onéreux après la
marguerite de tonnes il faudra encore
attendre quelques semaines pour pouvoir
orner nos tables où nos maisons de
branche de gui ou de houe
et avant de refermer cette édition je
vous laisse découvrir ce nouveau cliché
de thomas pesquet postés sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis la station spatiale
internationale l'astronaute français
dont la mission touche à sa fin a donc
publié cette photographie aérienne de
versailles un dernier souvenir avant sa
descente sur terre prévu le 4 ou 5
novembre thomas pesquet aura passé plus
de six mois en orbite le journal revient
mercredi 18h avec grégory canal et dans
un instant sur tv 78 l'actualité
culturelle dont six dans les yvelines
n'avait votre magazine 7,8 culture on se
retrouvera très prochainement sur cette
antenne
[Musique]